You know louis c.k a while back talked about Tiger Woods, which and I really liked it because people were complaining about Tiger Woods
in his affairs yeah, and also about our Arnold Schwarzenegger and his affairs and and
One of the things that Louie CK pointed out...quite in a very comical manner was that
well
Many men aren't having the affairs of Tiger Woods
But that's not because they're good men. It's because they don't have I think he said a busload of
Swedish Swedish bikini models waiting for them at the final hole
So the idea would be that you should conduct yourself so that you are attractive to
Many women maybe that you have your pick of them, but then you should pick one
And that's a sacrifice obviously. That's a sacrifice of a sort. It's it's a strange sacrifice because you know I
to someone a comedian recently who told me of one of his experiences in Las Vegas, so he went to Las Vegas with a
sports
superstar and
They went to a party and what literally happened at the party was one woman
brought forward a small group of other women all very attractive and basically told
The sports legend that he could just pick one of them
And she would go home with him right and so that had all been arranged beforehand, and he said that he's been in many
Situations where something like that has happened, and I thought
Well, you know that sort of is appealing to the Hugh Hefner
playboy 14 year old fantasy that sort of gripped our culture from the 1960s onward but
imagine that you sleep
casually with a hundred women in
In a six month period or a three month period for that matter or a three week period I don't care...pick your timeframe
And you say well
what what and you're you're you're
ecstatic with yourself because you've been validated by this opportunity, and I'm not
Making light of that. It's not nothing to be attractive to women like that. It's really something to be attractive to women
But it isn't obvious to me that
Your choice to conduct yourself in that manner
Enriches your life and the life of other people
More in any way than picking one person and actually having a relationship with them. It's only true that that
promiscuous pathway, let's say
Is better if you can actually divorce sexuality from all the other elements of life say well, it's about variety
And it's about impulsive pleasure. Or, maybe it could be even slightly deeper than merely impulsive pleasure
It could be shared impulsive pleasure, but I don't think you can do that because sexuality isn't divorceable from
Family and from morality and from all the other elements of your life, and if you're mature
You know that and so you make a decision you make of a decision not to
capitalize on your opportunity, not to misuse your opportunities
And you know, a huge part of the #MeToo phenomena the huge part of this battle that's being played out in our culture is a
consequence of the failure of men to recognize that -- now it's not only the failure of men
let me be absolutely clear about that because for example with the, um,
example of the sports superstar the women who are lining up in front of him parading themselves and offering themselves are deeply
complicit in, in this pathological game, and so it's pretty clear anthropologically as well that, you know
Sexual choice tends towards a Pareto distribution especially for men so most men have very little
selection at their disposal disposal and a small number of men have
excess opportunities...the question is what should that small number of men do? And you might say
capitalize on it and to hell with the consequences and like
It's a powerful argument, but I do believe it's wrong, it destabilizes the society and so
and I also don't think it does your soul any good because the problem with treating other people as casual sexual partners
let's say, is that you also treat yourself that way simultaneously, and I don't think that that does you any good, because you're not...
...unless that's what you want to be if you want to be a casual partner. It's like well
That's I wouldn't say that's a particularly noble ambition. You should be able to do better than that